expulsion actually isn't enough  aoc  can only deal with the expulsion part  because she's not law enforcement she's  a legislator but it actually isn't  enough  we should be talking about criminal  charges here if applicable  when the evidence points to that what i  mean is there should not be a now  criminal charges now  because these are members of congress it  needs to be looked at as if these were  any other people now realistically we're  not going to see the expulsion aoc is  right we should see it we're not going  to see it it would take a two-thirds  vote  um  to expel any member  this will never happen given the narrow  margins instead what probably needs to  happen  is the prosecution needs to happen and  then  that will make these folks  ineligible in theory if convicted and  immediately removed